welcome back
so I'm going through a high level
overview of the chapters in this control
for societal scale challenges roadmap
2030 document this is a really cool
collaborative effort by dozens of some
of my favorite control theorists on
planet Earth to outline what are the
large societal scale challenges that we
humans face and how is control theory
Central in solving these challenges in
the future
I'm going to zoom into chapter four
emerging methodologies and these are
specifically kind of the big emerging
methodologies in control theory that are
at the frontiers of research that are
driving new and advanced capabilities in
control that we can use to solve some of
these societal challenges things that
are going to make our control systems
learn better from data that are making
our control systems more robust and
higher performance and more resilient
things like that really cool chapter
this one's pretty close to my own
research activities and interests so
it's something I'm really excited about
if you know me you know that I'm going
to have probably you know dozens of
videos on subtopics in this but again I
highly recommend you to download this
roadmap
uh read it yourself you can I'll put a
link in the description below and read
this chapter because there's a lot more
here that I'm not going to be able to
tell you about I'm just giving you the
mile high overview in this video
okay so what are the kind of pieces and
subsections here we're going to talk
about learning and data driven control
again something very near and dear to my
heart is how does the interface of
machine learning and data intensive
science Advance our data-driven control
capabilities huge area hugely exciting
big challenges here how do you make
learning systems that are certifiable
that are trustworthy that are
explainable these are things we're still
wrapping our heads around but these are
where we need excellent people like you
to be working on these Solutions
safety critical systems again we need
our systems if they're going to be
solving societal scale problems if we're
going to be deploying robots all over
the globe or autonomy we need these
systems to be safe and and kind of
verifiably safe trustworthy there's a
lot of uh aspects and subtlety to how to
develop safety critical Engineering
Systems that are discussed here really
really important something you know I am
excited to learn more about in this
roadmap as well
uh resiliency is kind of another side of
this coin that if we have these large
sale scale societal systems and
infrastructure we need them to be
resilient especially cyber physical
systems uh how do you use control theory
to design these resilient cyber physical
systems that is an emerging set of
methodologies that's going to be
critical in solving societal scale
challenges that we discussed before
and if you want to see any of those
previous topics of what are the societal
drivers what are the technological
Trends those videos have already been
released and so you can check those out
to give context to this chapter which
Builds on those
similar to cyber physical assist we have
cyber physical human systems this has
been an important area of control theory
research for as long as I've been in the
field things like you know human robot
interactions and things like that really
interesting and important area of
research
whoop I think I went too far uh and then
control architectures this is something
I actually have only recently learned
about from some of the collaborators and
colleagues that are authors of of this
roadmap are things like how does the
foundational design architecture how you
design an engineering system and the
control systems that interact with that
system how do those architectural
choices affect things like resiliency
and performance and robustness and so
I've learned a ton from people like John
Doyle and others about how architecture
is really a foundational Concept in
control theory especially in the future
of control systems where you're going to
have layered architectures tons of
complexity abstraction it's a really
cool area again something I've only
recently learned about in the last 12 or
24 months but it's changed my entire way
that I think about control and
Engineering Systems so very very cool
highly recommend that you read more
about this
I'm going to only zoom in on a couple of
these right I'm going to probably talk
mostly about learning and data driven
control because that's my bread and
butter field but again read about this
yourself get up to speed on what these
emerging methodologies are this is kind
of the new tool set you're going to have
access to to solve those challenges
so learning and control go hand in hand
in my book data-driven science and
engineering with Nathan Kutz you know we
Advocate that control is inherently a
data driven uh discipline because you're
taking sensor measurements and you're
changing the system and then you're
measuring how that system change and if
there's data in kind of every step of
the system
and so in this kind
of kind of control system diagram there
is opportunity for learning for
data-driven learning in the modeling
side when we do model predictive control
we can use machine learned models to
model those Dynamics and then do
classical control things with them
we can apply our learning directly to
the controller this is kind of the
machine learning reinforcement learning
perspective can we use intelligence in
our control design directly and
interface with complex environments in a
complex real world
learning can also be useful for sensor
and actuator placement and processing
that data lots and lots and lots of
opportunities for learning in control
again I have dozens of videos on this
specific you know subsection but I
highly recommend you read the
perspective in this roadmap because
it'll give you the perspective not just
of me but of dozens of excellent
researchers and you know I think that
this is this is well known science that
when you have a diversity of opinions
kind of Taken collectively you learn a
lot more than if you just have one
person with a lot of opinions
okay so reinforcement learning super
exciting field this is kind of uh
exemplifies this this marriage of
control and learning this is a field
that's been around for decades really
old really rich field but just in the
last 10 years or so there have been some
incredible advances in reinforcement
learning
and I think we're only going to see this
trend increasing in the next decade okay
again I have a short video sequence on
reinforcement learning that talks about
kind of what are the controls challenges
what are the the machine learning
challenges what are you know what is
solvable today that wasn't just five
years ago and what do we think will be
solvable in five years so reinforcement
learning super exciting again it's
learning for control
uh this is an old one actually this
video you know can you teach a robot to
imitate an expert human that's a type of
imitation learning this is again
something we've been doing for a long
time for decades but the tools are so
much better than they were we have
better sensors better data storage and
transfer we have faster computers lower
latency better robots better sensors
better actuators kind of all of this is
advancing at an incredible pace and it's
really driving our capabilities in
learning for control
um you know like this that is this
really going to be driven by Machine
learning so we have lots of examples of
physics-based control systems uh
robotics is a great example increasingly
they are incorporating learning into
into the control design and how they
work with unstructured environments
self-driving cars is a pretty good
example where it is largely learning
based and learning driven reinforcement
learning and vision based and things
like that and we've said for a while you
know I have a lot of collaborators in
the Aerospace industry that future
systems are going to need kind of The
Best of Both Worlds and when you put a
learning based controller on a plane or
a car or in a robot they had better be
kind of physics either informed or
constrained
explainable trustworthy safe there are
these really essential characteristics
we need these controllers to have for
them to safely integrate into societal
scale deployment and you know that's
going to drive advances in how we do
machine learning and how we do machine
learning for control really really
exciting area
and then I'm just going to throw this up
as a last example this is different from
learning for control but just as a
teaser for architectures
architectures uh in control theory is a
really powerful concept where you think
about how do you take a very complex
system and Abstract it into layers that
interface with each other through some
kind of common agreed upon interface so
that each of those layers can be
independently optimized and tweaked and
played around with so a really good
example of a kind of common agreed upon
interface is the 110 volt 60 hertz power
interface that you know all of our
energy resources funnel into this
standard and then all of our devices
feed off of that standard so this is a
nice example where you can optimize and
do all kinds of things before and after
this layer but this kind of interface
allows these things to work together
and so I've heard examples of like a
smartphone you know it has a hardware
layer it has a software layer it has the
operating system layer which is what the
human interacts with which is just a
thin piece of software on top of the
software layer and these are all
abstracted so the hardware can change
the OS can change and things like that
without the other pieces necessarily
having to change
and so the idea of a layered
architecture allows you to get the best
of both worlds of performance and
robustness if you have performance
trade-offs you might think about
introducing new layers into this
architecture to exploit the different
kind of characteristics of the
constituent pieces this is a huge area
something I'm still learning about but I
truly and firmly believe that this is
going to change how we teach controls
how we design Control Systems especially
at scale for multi-physics multi-scale
problems so just a teaser but I think
this is super cool architectures are
changing how I think about control
theory
okay so that's chapter four emerging
methodologies very very cool you know
this is all the Sci-Fi advances in
control theory and so you know for you
young or old junior or senior
researchers right like this is kind of
where we're going and so it's exciting
and I highly recommend you read about
these from the world's experts you know
who who crafted and wrote this this very
nice chapter all right thank you